the gyro can experience yeah I mean this
is like what we're talking about with us
growing up that life was rougher the
life is easier today and but you have
more access to information so maybe it
could be better
and then things seem to be moving in a
better direction in terms of things
being safer less violence less crime
less rape and then people also get upset
at you bringing up those statistics
that's where it's really interested
inker gets attacked for just stating
statistical facts just say and he's not
making value judgments he's just saying
hey things are if you look at the
overall numbers of things this is the
safest time to be alive ever it's many
people know but what about this what
about that like it's a horrible hallmark
of our era that we live in that facts
almost always come second yes your
political agenda comes first
yeah and if it doesn't fit in then we
don't want to hear those facts and
that's the left and the right it is the
left and the right it's both and it's
it's it should be it should be something
that everybody rejects it should be
something that angers everyone it
shouldn't be tied to one party or
another party and it really should be
something that if there's a there's a
real problem with communication in this
society one of them is the denial of
actual facts and information if we if we
know things we have rock-solid threats
it's whether it's about climate change
it's about war the budget whatever the
[ __ ] it is if you have a real number yes
and you want to spin and deny and like
that that's a giant problem it's a giant
problem right I get madder at the left
because I want them to be better and
they should be better and they're they
they're the science party and they're
supposedly the fact people I expect this
[ __ ] from the right right denying
climate change and so forth they've been
doing that for a long time the left has
it's dirty thing if you disagree with
them in any way you become an alright
person like right I mean it's obviously
a small sliver or Ray's doing this yeah
boy I got stuck in this all right
category I'm like you guys are out of
your [ __ ] right exactly voted right
in my life right I know but there's a
there's a
I feel like I'm sure as you do sometimes
a man without a country ass and there's
a group of a Sam Harris yeah see people
you've had on yeah Jordan Peterson Barry
Weiss yeah you know I just we're all
progressives yeah but sensible
progressive real addresses real
progressives were not blindly not be
liable to our party yeah right and we
don't chase these virtues signalers yeah
who are always as a friend of mine said
they wake up offended yeah yeah and I
I'm always reading a story like daily I
read something and what goes through my
mind is this country now is completely
binary there's only two camps we're
totally tribal you either red or blue
liberal or conservative and everything
that one side does that anybody does
that represents that side has to be
owned by that entire side because people
go you all you're the party of so
whenever there's something on the left
that's cuckoo crazy we all own it yeah
and that's one reason why Trump won sure
because people you go through the
polling his fans are not oblivious to
his myriad flaws what they love about
him but they all said in love is he
wasn't politically correct it's it's
hard to measure how much people have
been choking on that political
correctness they do not want to walk on
eggshells yeah they do want do not want
to think that one little misstep and
they'll get fired or be castigated and
these are not just famous people I mean
these are the regular people and I think
when someone reads the kind of stories
you see every day and it's an eye-roll
and it's a I roll at the left that's
when you lose people a giving example is
about two weeks ago the Giants my
football team the New York Football
Giants cut took his name is generis
Jenkins in our word yes we have to say
the r-word no you could say [ __ ]
okay
we'll work we're just we're not saying
it I don't know what the [ __ ] rules
are yes and he okay first of all I don't
understand why that generation feels the
need to engage with their fans on
Twitter but he was and some God needs to
teach them social media some guy was
criticizing him and he's a good
quarterback or safety and whatever he is
and the was criticizing him and he
answered back yeah again I don't know
why but saying here are my stats I'm
pretty good I only can do my job right
and they're not [ __ ] mr. Bharat must
be nice part of the story I'm gonna
explain so then the guy the fan says
well why does it matter the team is
losing and that's when jinora jenkins
said I can only do my job [ __ ] and cut
like cut from the team cut yeah like the
next day and first of all I think he
said did something I thought it was a
hood thing you know maybe generous
Jenkins didn't get the memo because he's
not you know like on Twitter 24/7 and
living with the woke stirs that we don't
do this anymore
I think they offered him a chance to
apologize he said I think he did did he
I think he did did after they caught him
but yeah I don't think he liked student
I insist on saying that's what you know
that seems like there's no room anymore
for someone just to go oh sorry I didn't
realize this was such a thing because
you know they do move the goal posts
we're often and they like to because
it's easier to catch people that way so
that's just oh sorry I guess you know we
don't do this anymore my bed and move on
with our lives
instead of no you're canceled your cut
you are irredeemable yeah it's hot
ridiculous it's ridiculous and what I'm
saying is like every day there's some
story like that and it just all goes
into the bin left wing yeah and that's
when people go you know what Trump's an
[ __ ] I don't like him but I don't
want to live in that world these people
are even [ __ ] crazy
yeah and that is the great danger of
reelecting him and that very well may do
it
[Applause]